probably are quite an unfortunate
situation for you you came out with
blazing hot preparation but Anish just
defended immaculately tell us a bit
about your perspective Yeah we actually
discussed a bit after the game because I
was curious about like what he was
thinking during the game and he was also
I guess curious about about what I uh I
mean the what the position objectively
was but yeah he found everything
absolutely correct I mean this position
has been played a lot actually he knew
that there was a game Shanklin in the
urban uh ever let me
uh so he knew this game but it's
everyone plays Queen B3 everyone plays
this position and I saw there's like
some motlakov against krishu from title
Tuesday
where they play like H3 and like can
play many many possible moves and
so I came up with this
very rare movie I knew that it was
played in this game seems that only one
game has been played with this move yeah
and they actually they went up to I mean
black has many choices here so I was
thinking
maybe that this is a moment where Anish
would play something else besides ed4
because ed4 is very concrete and I
thought he could play C6 for example but
Bishop A3 discouraged that discourages
that a bit and then he has very
interesting moves Bishop G4
um H3 and either Bishop takes F3 or
Bishop H5 or Knight F4
so basically black can play anything at
this point more or less yeah I can play
Anything For example D5 is a move that
was very tempting to him and it looks
very tempting but he spotted this trick
but uh it's it's the only reason why
this is bad but the bishop gets kind of
solidified on D5 with C4
um so he he's saw this and he said that
he wasn't like considering Knight F4
Bishops before even I understand why
because they're interesting moves uh but
they're not super concrete so he was
going for the more concrete stuff it's
very very sensible and yeah there was a
game with Bishop B6 here where black is
a bit worse I was hoping that I might
get that position which it's not it's
not concrete like basically I mean black
is not doing terribly here but white has
the center Queen C2 and a slight
advantage certainly
and this is
yeah the thing is like
DC3 is very accurate if he had gone for
this I think that this is really
difficult for black
to uh to play because you you can go for
this position
but white has this very tricky move
queen and I thought
I thought he might not be too afraid of
this because it looks like
yeah you're pinned but but you I mean
why it has to do something uh because
Queen D7 is coming right so it's
possible to maybe overlook this move and
then you get into basically so the point
being that after Queen is there Queen E4
Queen E4 and F5 Queen E2 I think I think
this is the line another four Queen E7
um because there's like a May 135
actually I I was trying to figure this
out over the board because I have no
idea what
I mean I I didn't think that I would get
to this at this point I was considering
this position
and couldn't understand it but I thought
it's so dangerous like I see the
computer says
B6
but I thought King E2 was winning a
piece
F4 okay yeah I didn't see this F4 yeah
yeah I so I was calculating this but uh
understandably he didn't want to
deal for it
was this still in your files if you I
just knew Queen I just knew Queen C4
that was that was it I mean the position
from the start is like not concrete at
all so basically it's difficult to
analyze everything and Bishop 5 here is
also possible 95 and it's again a mess
but it's dangerous for black
but I really thought he would be
attracted to Knight takes E8
um and he spent a lot of time well at
least
yeah I thought he would be attracted to
this position because it's it's more or
less a normal position yeah and the
position is equal and I also haven't
like prepared anything here I just knew
that it's a more or less playable
position uh but I have like an hour time
Advantage so you can play so this was my
my hope that I have a playable position
our time advantage and it looks fine for
black so I thought maybe he would you
know put his Knight here we would get
something like this and uh yeah it's
probably about equal but uh continue the
game for a while the game continues and
I was very disappointed when he
basically just played everything and
after Queen E8 everything is forced
right yeah I mean at this point I
understood that of course he's he's
going to take I mean
there wasn't much hope that he would
play Queen d8
the problem is that in this position
white actually loses with any of them
but like I think King F1 loses to Bishop
G4 and then Bishop takes a three and
Knight F2 or Knight C3 ideas
um so white is white hand is forced and
it's not very difficult to calculate
because you have this mechanism so like
why it doesn't have checks which is the
only thing that would be scary for black
so you just have this mechanism which
draws yeah um so yeah overall like
Danish um
did everything absolutely correct today
yeah uh difficult well not so difficult
but uh still disappointing really late
again without with more time on my clock
than when I finished much more time like
five five minutes or so so five minutes
is a long time that's an accomplishment
well you don't unfortunately get extra
points for for the time you saved up
between the tournament you're a
co-leader going into uh this round
alireza is under some pressure how would
you assess this position right now
I mean I feel like white is definitely
better but under pressure is a bit uh
difficult to say because he has ideas so
it's not like he's passive which I think
he played a good decision here to take
on G3 because if you play this kind of
position then you have no counter play
and white just plays H4 and the King on
D2 is safe yeah so he he made a good
decision to uh
should I see that
like fg3 was an option but okay h23 is
kind of normal like you open the they
trial
um like young Kristoff is playing
extremely principled right he's just
grabbing the pawn and then what we're
going to see is probably I mean H5 or
queen F6 I don't know okay some queen of
six something like this
um so white is going to be a pull up and
black is trying to find some kind of
play yeah you get H4 and you white king
is a bit I see the computer hates it but
in Practical game it's not like let's
see what
and Bishop G6 but this is like I don't
see what it changes I don't see what
this changes so so I think normally you
play H5
and then maybe you but the thing is H4
you'll probably like run into taken
Queen E7
so
so you maybe you should play Queen of
maybe G4 to stop this Knight F3 is a
good idea you could even consider it at
this moment yeah yeah just stop stop
Knight F3 because
um
like given time white white is going to
be winning so you need to stop the the
counter play with Knight of three E5
Fabi thank you very much for your
insights you still have one game left
against Richie we'll let you go get
ready for that and we'll see you
tomorrow
thank you Christian thank you Fab